I do want to tell everybody about
something very special we're doing for
our shows here at Comic Con we've
brought back our conan 360 camera let me
explain it's a camera that shoots
everything is beautiful it's beautiful
in 360 degrees now conan 360 is an
interactive experience where you the
viewer can watch our show online while
controlling the 360 degree camera
allowing you to look anywhere you want
in the theater but that's not all conan
360 is now virtually virtually virtual
reality and abled was you're ready to go
drinking you can use it it's San Diego
you have to you can use it with these
special team Koko virtual reality
headsets now check this out
this is 100% real it features amazing
cardboard technology
when you put one of these VR headsets
it's like you're sitting right here on
the couch with us and trust me that's
not pleasant earlier tonight I decided
to surprise some of our audience members
way up in the back row of the balcony by
giving them a headset yes now the rest
of the theater hates you know they put
their smartphones in the headsets and
now they've got a virtual reality
upgrade to the best seats in the house
they are controlling the cameras right
now they can look around they can see
anything it's creepy and probably
illegal nobody looks cool just different
sealing a ceiling low the sad thing is
some of them didn't put phones in them
it's amazing those of you at home with
headsets can go to team koco.com slash
360 to experience all of this and thanks
to our friends at AT&T for sponsoring
Kona 360 now with virtual reality
[Applause]